una victoria para los refugiados sirios
en alemania el tribunal de justicia de
koblenz condenó al ex agente de
seguridad sirio
al garib de 44 años por ayudar a
arrestar y transportar a manifestantes a
un centro de interrogatorios en 2011
conocido en damasco por ser también
centro de torturas durante la guerra
civil uno de los abogados y víctimas de
la represión siria se mostró optimista
por la decisión de la justicia
we'll be starts star así que espero que
sea el comienzo o tal vez vuelve
empezamos desde hace mucho tiempo pero
espero que esto sea una señal muy clara
de que la gente no es intocable
[Música]
trabajamos en ello desde hace mucho
tiempo desde 2017 cuando enviamos
archivos aquí en suecia y en noruega
contra oficiales de alto rango incluso
contra bachar al asad como sospechosos
de crímenes contra la humanidad pero los
sirios no revisaron ese trabajo ahora
todos lo ven durante el juicio los
abogados del condenado argumentaron que
se había ordenado al ex agente que
cometiera los presuntos delitos por
temor a ser castigado por
obediencia este juicio es el primer
proceso judicial en el mundo sobre los
crímenes del gobierno del presidente de
siria bachar al asad y su veredicto es
considerado histórico es importante más
importante que la duración del veredicto
es la existencia de un veredicto de
verdad
syrian un miembro del régimen sirio un
miembro del sistema violento está ahora
tras las rejas
[Música]
surfing behind parts se logró gracias a
que en alemania rige el principio de la
jurisdicción universal para crímenes de
lesa humanidad este país ha dado refugio
a cerca de 800.000 sirios que también
aseguran haber sido torturados el
veredicto le da esperanza a esta
comunidad que ha sufrido innumerables
atrocidades desde el estallido de la
guerra siria y que ha dejado al menos
medio millón de muertos